the modern office is all about perks
free food foosball and other seemingly
amazing conveniences that actually exist
to keep us in the office working for as
long as possible here at Bloomberg we
have snacks for days why go out to lunch
when you can make a perfectly good meal
out of carrots and chips we're running
out of reasons to leave the office which
is why I'm concerned about an app called
pager essentially pager connects
patients with doctors and care providers
in general for only men health care
pager is like seamless for when you're
sick and this month the company is
launching a service where employees can
order doctors right to the office I
don't think that employers are
particularly sensitive to where we care
is delivered as long as it is done in a
very efficient way so that the employees
can get can stay healthy and work better
it makes sense that employers would love
the efficiency but do people really want
their doctor's appointments at the
office I haven't been to the doctor in
probably two years seems like a good
time to test page or out I think I need
a physical and confirm hello this is
Rebecca
I don't understand that thank you what
message I'm in a voicemail vortex of
hell seven robo calls later we sorted it
out and the doctor came to our office hi
nice to meet you thanks for coming yeah
is there somewhere private we can go our
office has an open floor plan and this
must be a constant problem for pager
open offices might have their creative
benefits but they definitely don't work
for doctor's visit we did our best to
find somewhere somewhat private feel a
little exposed I'm not gonna lie there's
like a coat closet
I might even should we go to the coat
closet right okay there's a Purell
machine yeah it's perfect a closet isn't
an ideal location to get a check-up I
didn't really want to talk about my
sexual history and reproductive health
in a room without a door but it took a
lot less time than any other doctor's
appointment I've been to as a working
person I can definitely see the appeal
for someone who wants quick relief or
just needs a quick prescription the
pager does make it harder for me to fake
an appointment just to get out of the
office at least the doctor seemed to
enjoy it it really gives you a nice
personal experience with the patient
it's just so much better for the
patient's doctor experience on both ends
I think especially on a coat closet I
think I got a great experience